>> Greg: ANYONE MORE BITTER THAN
THE LEFT ON TWITTER.
ELON MUSK WILL LAYOFF HALF OF
TWITTER'S WORK FORCE.
3700 PEOPLE.
MUSK WANTS TO REDUCE FOR
OVERPAYING FOR THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM.
THE OPPOSITE OF HOW OUR
GOVERNMENT IS RUN.
MUSK WILL ENFORCE THE RETURN TO
OFFICE POLICY SO EMPLOYEES CAN'T
WORK FROM HOME IN FORTS MADE OF
PILLOWS.
AOC IS TAKING A BREAK FROM DOING
NOTHING TO GET IN A BEEF WITH
THE TWITTER CHIEF.
MUSK PLANS TO CHARGE PEOPLE $8
FOR THE VERIFIED BLUE CHECKMARK
STATUS.
HE SAID YOUR FEEDBACK IS
APPRECIATED.
PAY $8.
HE WOULD LOVE TO SPEND THE $8
BUT SHE ALREADY BOUGHT A TESLA.
SHE HAS MERCHANDISE SHE IS
TRYING TO HAWK.
IT MAKES YOU FULL OF [BLEEP].
TYRUS, YOU KNOW I DON'T LIKE TO
SWEAR.
>> YOU HAD TO.
>> Greg: HE IS FORCING TWITTER
EMPLOYEES TO WORK NOW.
>> THAT'S CRAZY.
DON'T LET THIS THING GET OVER
HERE.
>> Greg: [LAUGHING].
>> I DON'T THINK I HAVE EVER
BEEN TO ONE OF YOUR MEETINGS.
>> Greg: I WENT BY YOUR OFFICE
AND YOU HAVE A GIANT RECLINER.
>> YES.
IT USED TO BE ON THE SET.
>> Greg: THAT'S RIGHT.
>> IT WAS REPARATIONS FOR THE
WAY MY AN  ANCESTORS WERE
TREATED.
I ASSUMED YOU DIDN'T WANT TO GO
TO COURT.
NO WAY I COULD FIT A MULE IN MY
OFFICE SO I TOOK THE CHAIR.
I DON'T AGREE WITH AOC ON MUCH.
WE HAVE COME TO THINK THE BLUE
CHECK IS VERIFYING.
IF SOMEONE PAYS FOR IT COULD BE
A PEDOPHILE PRETENDING TO BE THE
PERSON BEHIND THE BLUE CHECK.
HE HAS A BLUE CHECK.
THAT'S MY CONCERN.
ACROSS THE BOARD I HAVE NO
PROBLEM PAYING $8 SO WE KNOW
EVERYONE WHO SAYS THEY ARE.
YOU NEED TO BE AN I.D. ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
WE ELIMINATE THE CAT FISHING AND
PEOPLE TRYING TO HURT PEOPLE.
I HOPE ELON MUSK GOES IN THAT
DIRECTION.
HAVE BLUE CHECKS IS EVERYBODY IS
WHO SAY THEY SAY ARE.
>> Greg: CAT YOU MADE THIS POINT
ON A LESSER SHOW.
I AM JOKING.
IT WAS TO MAKE SURE PEOPLE
DIDN'T IMPERSONATE.
NOW IT'S A STATUS SYMBOL.
I AM A BLUE CHECK AND YOU ARE
NOT, BAKER.
YOU ARE NOT, ARE YOU?
>> [LAUGHING].
>> NO.
LOOK AT ME I PAY FOR TWITTER.
>> Greg: THAT'S HOW IT TEALS IN
A WEIRD WAY.
>> I GET WHY AOC DOESN'T WANT TO
$8 A MONTH.
SHE GAVE HIM ALL OF THOSE OTHER
DOLLARS WHEN SHE BOUGHT OR
TESLA.
IT'S ANNOYING.
SHE SAYS ATTENTION SEEKING
ABSURD STUFF.
PEOPLE GO AFTER HER.
WHY ARE YOU SO OBSESSED WITH ME?
BECAUSE YOU ARE SAYING ATTENTION
SEEKING STUFF AND PEOPLE ARE
PAYING ATTENTION TO YOU.
LIKE A STRIPPER, WHY ARE YOU
WATCHING ME DANCE?
>> Greg: THAT HAPPENS A LOT.
>> YOU BEHAVE THAT WAY SO PEOPLE
WILL PAY ATTENTION TO YOU.
>> Greg: LIKE WHEN PEOPLE HARASS
YOU AND OH, I STUCK A NERVE.
>> WOW, A REALLY GOT TO YOU
THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
GO PLAY WITH YOUR GRANDKIDS,
WEIRDO.
>> Greg: THAT WAS A JAB AT YOU,
MIKE.
I LIKE THE WAY ELON MUSK IS
RUNNING THE COMPANY.
HE IS TWEETING OUT THE IDEAS FOR
PRICING.
HE IS LETTING PEOPLE IN ON HOW
IT'S DONE WHICH IS LIKE LET'S
SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IT'S A GOOD WAY TO RUN THIS
COMPANY.
>> HE IS ON TO SOMETHING.
I LIKE ALL OF THE PEOPLE OUT
THERE THAT ARE UPSET WITH THE
FACT HE HAS THE COMPANY WHO ARE
TRYING TO GIVE HIM BUSINESS
ADVICE.
AOC, THE IRRITATING PART IS SHE
IS LIKE ONE OF THOSE TIKTOK
STARS BUT SHE'S IN CONGRESS.
WE SHOULD EXPECT MORE.
I WILL YIELD MY TIME ON MUSK AND
AOC BECAUSE I AM UPSET ABOUT
BIDEN.
I SPENT MOST OF MY LIFE
OVERSEAS.
THE PEOPLE THE DEMS ARE TALKING
TO SAYING IT'S THE DEATH OF
DEMOCRACY IF YOU DON'T VOTE FOR
US.
PEOPLE WHO BUY THAT DON'T
APPRECIATE THIS COUNTRY OR NEVER
BEEN OVERSEAS.
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME OVERSEAS.
I HAVE SEEN FRAIL DEMOCRACIES.
I TOPPLED A FEW OF THEM.
WE ARE NOT FRAIL.
THIS IS A STRONG COUNTRY.
ANYBODY WHO BELIEVES THAT CRAP
IS SO PARTISAN THEY WILL SEE
NOTHING ELSE.
I AM VERY UPSET ABOUT IT.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: FEEL FREE TO TALK ABOUT
THE SEGMENT AT HAND OR DO WHAT
MIKE DID AND TALK ABOUT
ANYTHING.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I GOT $8 FOR ELON MUSK.
I WANT $8 TO BE SPENT ON MARK
ZUCKERBERG NOT SHADOW BAN ME.
>> Greg: WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> GASLIGHT.
>> Greg: I HAVE BEEN GAS LIT AND
SHADOW BANNED.
>> SHADOW BANNED SOUNDS LIKE
A MARVEL HERO.
HOW DID YOU FIND ME HERE?
>> UNLIKE THOSE MUSIC GROUPS YOU
MAKE US LISTEN TO.
>> Greg: COMING